and help us see more clearly what the
future holds
dr fauci has been the leading public
health voice during the coven 19
pandemic and is the chief medical
advisor to president joe biden
during his career dr fauci has led the
federal response to all major disease
outbreaks over the last 40 years
including hiv aids ebola sars mers zika
and anthrax he is also an architect of
one of the most successful disease
prevention programs in the world the
president's emergency plan for aids
relief pepfar a program that addresses
the global hiv aids epidemic begun in
2003 under president george w bush
pepfar is estimated to have saved the
lives of 21 million people
like dr fauci's three daughters i too
grew up as a child of an infectious
disease specialist and epidemiologist
i'm sure we can all swap dinners about
what dinner swap stories about what
dinner conversations were like growing
up in our houses but unlike a few of
those dinner conversations growing up i
very much look forward to dr fauci's
insight as we continue to navigate our
lives in this long pandemic dr fauci
thank you for joining us today the floor
is yours
thank you very much jen it's really good
to be with you all
i'm going to spend uh some minutes
talking about some of the lessons that
we've learned
from covet 19 in our pandemic
preparedness
and response and then hopefully we'll
have the opportunity to entertain
questions from the group
so just to put things in perspective we
know now we're about
two and a half years into the pandemic
which was first recognized in the first
days of january 2020
of cases of an unusual pneumonia that
were identified now retrospectively
likely in december or earlier of 2019
in the central region of china called
wuhan
if you now fast forward
to where we are today and look at the
global pandemic and look at cases per
hundred thousand
and you could see that in the color code
of the density throughout the world now
we have about five hundred
and eight million cases and more than
six million deaths the death count is
likely
considerably underestimated and the
number is likely more than that
so here are some of the lessons that
i'll very quickly buzz through making
comments
on each of them
but really just to stimulate discussion
first is the global information
information sharing
and the collaborations which are
absolutely essential
to any adequate response or preparation
for a global pandemic
so here we have schematically diagrammed
the kinds of things that one does namely
to share research reagents
real world clinical data viral isolates
genomic data
vaccine research center and what it
means is that you take a particular
category
of pathogens a family
and you build on
prior experiences
with that family of pathogens
and these are some of the families
that are on the high priority list
the one that are obviously most familiar
is the coronaviruses which gave us saws
one mares
and now saws kobe 2.
the orthomyxoviruses which are the
different influenzas
the flaviviruses which is
west nile and dengue and others
and what you do is that you take
commonalities within a family
such as basic virology
assays animal models
anagenic targets
vaccine platforms correlates of immunity
as well as manufacturing strategies
and you develop it for one of those
so-called prototype pathogens and you
find
there are many similarities within that
that allow you
to jump ahead when you get a new
pathogen
within that family the same exact way
when sauce kovi ii came along
our experience in 2002 with saw's kobe 1
and mayors in 2012
allowed us to move extremely
rapidly
next
the continued surveillance of the human
animal interface is absolutely critical
75
of all new pathogens are zoonotic
namely
pathogens that infect humans 75 percent
of them that are new come from an animal
host
and in fact my colleague and i
david morins
wrote last year in cell
that the imbalance of the interactions
in the animal human interface
are a major component
of outbreaks be it influenza
ebola
coronavirus or what have you
namely the human health clearly is
connected to the health of animals
as we've seen in so many
outbreaks
some recent example
is now
mounting evidence
that
the cause of kobe 2 outbreak
was the result of a jumping of species
from an animal to a human
similar to sauce kov-1 which went from a
bat
to a civet cat to a human in mares which
went from a bat
to a camel to a human
that is still though though we don't
know precisely what the origin is it is
very likely that that is the case
despite the fact
that the lab leak hypothesis still
obviously has not been disproven
next
long-standing systemic health and social
inequities that we see
are driving pandemic disparities we've
seen it with virtually every disease
again this has been written about
recently
that the most pervasive disparities are
seen among our minority populations
african americans latino
and where we have data also american
indian alaskan natives and pacific
islanders why is that the case
why do we see such disparities well
the answer to that has been obvious for
decades the underlying discrimination
and the results of long-standing racism
has led
to a
disadvantage that minorities have been
put at by limited health care access and
use
by some of their occupations which
disproportionately put them
in essential work settings
as opposed to the easy ability to work
remotely
the way many people are able to do
there are educational income and wealth
gaps
housing issues where some people live in
crowded conditions
and it's hard to follow prevention
strategies
and finally what about misinformation
we are seeing a heavy dose
of that in the current pandemic
and here are some of the crazy examples
of what we have to deal with
when the common enemy unquestionably is
the virus
and these are some of the things that
all you know
bill gates and i putting microchips and
vaccines
that might actually make somebody
magnetic not to mention following what
they're doing the widespread
misinformation about infertility
related to covert 19 vaccines
the extraordinary destructive
anti-vaccine propaganda
of robert f kennedy jr senators who say
that covert vaccines are killing
athletes on the playing field
and also a variety of other myths and
disinformation
so
with those lessons learned
getting back to covet now what's the end
game
looking ahead this year
and beyond
let me explain
something that has recently
maybe had some misinterpretation
of a description of different phases of
the pandemic so let me try and clarify
it now
when you look at pandemics there are
five ways of looking at it and what i
call different phases
let's start off
with the phase of eradication are we
going to eradicate
covadine team
i say that's almost impossible we've
only eradicated one human viral pathogen
in history
and that is smallpox and the reason we
eradicated it there was no animal
reservoir it was phenotypically stable
smallpox from 100 years ago
is the same as smallpox 50 years ago
and 40 years ago
there was a widely accepted global
vaccination campaign
and importantly
the immunity that was induced
by either vaccine or infection was
lifelong in its durability
the next question can we eliminate it
that means we don't eradicate it from
the world
but you eliminate it from certain
regions for example the united states
what about that
we've successfully eliminated two
important viral pathogens
in the united states
polio in 1979
and measles in 2000
how is that possible again
lack of an animal reservoir
a phenotypically stable virus measles
from 50 years ago
60 years ago is the same as measles
that's circulating in parts of the world
now
in the united states we had a widely
accepted
national vaccination campaign
and again
either vaccine or infection-induced
immunity is usually
lifelong or close to life-long
so what about saws
why do i say it's unlikely we will
eliminate it one
there are established animal reservoirs
and we know
there can be re-infections and
reintroductions although we don't need
it there's enough people that are
already infected
but importantly
unlike measles and smallpox and polio
we have already seen
the evolution of genotypically and
phenotypically diverse variants the
world has experienced five of them
already
we in the united states have experienced
four
there is unfortunately
a lack of wide acceptance of safe and
effective vaccines with the anti-vax
movement and then unfortunately as we've
experienced
both vaccine and infection-induced
immunity
wanes over a period of several months
so what are we hoping for
we're hoping for control namely
get out of the fulminant
acute pandemic phase where you have 900
000 infections a day
tens of thousands of
hospitalizations 3 000 deaths per day
and get to a level
low enough
so that it doesn't disrupt the society
either economically
socially from the standpoint of what we
can do
in schools and in jobs
and what i mean by that some people call
it return to normalcy or at least a new
normal
some people refer to it as endemicity
others describe it by saying something
similar
to what we see with other viral
infections that are present
we don't like them to be present but
they're present
but they don't disrupt society
things like rsv respiratory syncytial
virus common cold coronaviruses para
influenza influenza
how do we stay in control
well you get it to a low enough level
by vaccinating the overwhelming
proportion of the population and
boosting where necessary
but also you implement common sense
hygiene
voluntary masking attention to good
ventilation
and make available vaccines antivirals
and monoclonal antibodies
i'll stop with this last slide
going back 14 years to something
i wrote with my colleagues in the lancet
infectious diseases
in which i briefly described that
emerging infectious diseases
has been with us since the beginning of
civilization
from before the time we could record it
we've seen it in recorded history
with diseases like pandemic flu of 1918
we've seen it with three subsequent
pandemics
of influenza
and we're experiencing it now
with covert 19.
and the bottom line is since these
infections are perpetual challenges
we absolutely must
be perpetually prepared for the
inevitability
of another pandemic
thank you thank you so much for those uh
opening remarks uh tons of very good
information in there um
on wednesday you told the washington
post that the pandemic was in a
transitional phase and you talked a
little bit about this in your opening
remarks
from a deceleration of the numbers into
hopefully a more controlled phase an
endemicity if i'm pronouncing that
correctly uh tell us more about what
that means especially for those of us in
unmedical school uh environments what do
you mean by endemicity
yeah well i try to uh
already explained it a few minutes ago
but i'll go over it again
yes uh again there is the very acute
fulminant phase of an outbreak and the
other day when i said we are no longer
in that full-minute acute phase that
does not mean
that the pandemic is over by no means is
it over we still are experiencing a
global pandemic
when you talk about getting it to a
level of control
a level of control
really is not when you have tens of
thousands of hospitalizations and you
have a thousand or more two thousand
three thousand debts it's when you get
those levels
low enough
that it really is not disrupting you
don't overwhelm the hospital it isn't a
fearful threat throughout society
but there are going to be infections in
the community i don't think we're going
to completely eliminate that
and again
you could pick an arbitrary number of
how many cases or hospitalizations per
100 000 that would be
but it has to be low enough
that it's present but not disruptive
that's what i mean by some people
calling that endemicity some people
calling that return to normality but it
is something that doesn't
disrupt or influence profoundly how we
interact in society
okay thank you that was that was very
helpful i know that a lot of people are
looking out for you know the magic
numbers you know what does that look
like and and you know like you said it
it will be it may not necessarily be a
certain threshold or number
um does the study published by the cdc
and morbidity and mortality indicate the
u.s has reached the herd immunity
threshold
if not when will we get there is that
sooner or later than you expect
well i recently wrote a paper a few
weeks ago how the concept of how we
classically think of herd immunity
is likely unattainable
in covet 19. so i think we have to ex we
have to realize that because herd
immunity was the examples that i gave on
the slides a few minutes ago
when i showed what happens what we did
with measles what we did with polio
namely you had enough immunity in the
population with a stable virus that
doesn't change
that's classical herd immunity
it makes it very problematic
to get herd immunity which means there's
enough
protection in the community and enough
stability
of the virus that it doesn't change and
enough durability of protection that you
essentially don't have any infection in
the community
similar to what we see now
with measles and polio
measles in polio is all over the world
in some countries polio less so but
measles is widespread in many other
countries
yet we don't see measles in the united
states
because a
people are immune to it
and b the virus doesn't change
we're not seeing that with saw's kobe 2.
we're seeing variants that emerge every
few months we've had alpha beta delta
omicron ba2 ba4 bva5
so it's very difficult to really get a
strong classical hurt immunity
when you have immunity that wanes
and a virus that in fact
does not uh
stay stable
and you have an anti-vaxx movement
which prevents many of the people from
getting vaccinated so that's what i mean
when i described
recently
we're not going to get classical herd
immunity with sawz kobe 2.
okay let's talk about those variants so
why why do viruses evolve you know at
the moment it seems like the coronavirus
is becoming more communicable but less
lethal can you talk about why that is
well i you know generally when viruses
propagate rapidly through populations
they tend to adapt themselves to spread
more rapidly and not necessarily kill
all the hosts so it's not surprising
that you wind up seeing viruses that
might be less pathogenic but remember
less pathogenicity
can be due to two factors one
the virus can be inherently less
pathogenic namely serious or there's
enough baseline immunity in the
population
that even though you're not protected
from infection
you're protected from severity
of disease
now viruses change and evolve by
mutations
mutations
cause amino acid substitutions
in important parts of the virus
which interfere or modify their
transmissibility
or their severity that's usually due
to what we call immunological pressure
that's put on the virus
so when a virus infects somebody your
immune system
tries hard to eliminate it
the virus that's replicating
is trying to escape
that attack on it
by the immune system so it tends to
mutate and change
when you get enough of that
and then viruses start to recirculate
the new version of it recirculates and
that's called a variant
okay thank you um you spoke a little bit
about the zoonotic effect in
the animal reservoir for this particular
uh disease so
how have you seen that play out in the
united states um can you talk a little
bit about infection among animals and
have we seen
passing back and forth
yeah well we're dealing with it
literally yesterday
when the cdc announced the first case
of an
h5n1
chicken influenza virus
that jumped species
from the animal host the chicken which
is causing a great deal of agricultural
problems because it's causing the
culling of large numbers of chickens not
to mention wild birds
like bald eagles and other uh
singing birds
so that is an animal virus that's jump
species
years ago
we had a rather significant concern with
h5n1 h7n9 which are influenza viruses in
animals that jump species so right here
in the united states
interesting you ask that question we had
an announcement yesterday of that by the
cdc
okay thank you
while the initial version of the
vaccines were highly effective
the immunity they produced did not last
that long you you mentioned that in your
opening remarks
what can we expect from future vaccines
will they be able to extend immunity and
how will they do this
and kind of a schedule can we expect
once a year twice a year
you know based on the nature of the
virus will there ever be a one and done
well i hope there will be but i'm not
overly optimistic about a one-and-done
particularly when you have a virus that
tends to change
which this virus does and
test us ask the
variance that we've seen
so right now
i would hope
that we get to the point
where the immunity will last long enough
so that you only intermittently would
need to be
boosted i don't see
the necessity of every four months
requiring a boost i don't think that's
feasible and i don't think that's really
something that we'll be dealing with but
i do anticipate
that giving the fact that the immunity
does wane and that happens to be
characteristic
of coronaviruses i think people don't
fully appreciate
that prior to the covid
outbreak and prior to saw's kovi one and
mares
we've been dealing with four common cold
coronaviruses that account for you know
variable between five and thirty percent
of all the common colds
that we experience and we keep getting
infected
with the same for
common cold coronaviruses for decades
so we know from experience with
coronaviruses that
the
protection that follows
infection
is not particularly durable
and you would expect that being the case
that the protection following vaccines
are not going to be durable which brings
us to the second part of your question
we are trying very hard to develop
vaccines
different platforms
that give a greater degree of durability
of immunity
mrna vaccines are phenomenally good
at getting a high degree of efficacy and
safety
but we've experienced now
that the durability of protection isn't
lifelong for sure well certainly not
years long in the tree and the year and
a half that we've experienced it so
we've got to do better we have very good
vaccines
but we've got to get better platforms
and immunogens
maybe with adjuvants that allow us to
have a greater durability of protection
okay
uh so the second booster you know we're
already seeing that that's already
approved for uh those uh over the age of
50 something um but
when are you expecting uh to see a
release for that second booster for
adults and also potentially
young adults teenagers um
where are you with that and uh
do you think that the second booster is
something that people should consider
getting at this point or should we be
waiting for for something else all right
two two elements to your question
the first is what about approval or
eligibility for people younger than 50.
as you know the fda together with the
cdc
came out with a declaration of
eligibility for people 50 years of age
or older particularly those who are even
older than that 65 and older and
certainly with people
with underlying conditions
the fda right now with their verb their
advisory committee are looking at and
planning
what we might have
in the fall as we prepare
for the cooler season of the fall and
winter
which would likely lead to some sort of
a surge in cases so that's being
determined right now and we at the nih
are doing a number of studies to
determine what the best
boost would be that fourth dose should
it be a variant specific boost
should it be a bi-valent boost
we have a number of clinical studies
that are ongoing now to ask that
so a we likely will know over the summer
when we'll be able to and what we'll be
able to boost people with if you are in
that group
of 50 or older now
and you have any of a number of
underlying conditions hypertension
obesity heart disease diabetes we
recommend that you do get that fourth
dose
okay great
um so masks or no masks uh what kind of
masks can you give us some clear
guidance on you know what we should
expect in terms of use of masks going
forward you know when is it necessary
when is it unnecessary or really not all
that effective um if you had to get on a
plane tomorrow would you wear a mask
well if i had to get on a plane tomorrow
i would definitely wear a mask
so even though
you know the court order struck down the
uh requirement for masks on planes i
think that if you want to be protected i
mean
in a situation like that it's a person's
own individual choice for the risk that
they're willing to take and each
individual is different and they assess
their risk how old are you do you have
an underlying condition that it would
make it more likely that you would have
a severe outcome if you got infected do
you have someone in your household who
if you got infected even though you had
no symptoms
if you went home and infected them
is that someone who is vulnerable an
elderly person a person with an
underlying condition someone who might
be on chemotherapy for cancer or someone
who might have an immune defect an
autoimmune disease on corticosteroids or
methotrexate or something like that if
that's the case
you should probably take into
consideration seriously wearing a mask
even in indoor settings when masks are
not required
if you look at the united states now in
the cdc metrics
most of the country is green
which means the requirement or the
strong recommendation for mask and
indoor settings is not there as the cdc
has said
that could change and if in fact a
combination of cases
hospitalization and hospital capacity
change
the cdc will modify
their recommendations but the wearing of
masks
right now in indoor cases you need to
take a look at what your risk is and the
risk you're willing to take
okay
i want to jump over and ask a burning
question
selfishly but i know many people want to
know i have a two-year-old and a
three-year-old
we're all
just kind of continuously scouring the
news for answers on when we may see a
vaccine that covers under age of five
six months to five years
um on thursday moderna announced that it
would seek emergency use authorization
for the covid vaccine
for young children
why has it been so difficult to deliver
a vaccine that's suitable for toddlers
well first of all i think it's important
for the public to understand something
very clearly
the fda cannot act on approving
something on an emergency use until a
they get an application from the company
for an eua and b
they receive all of the information
necessary to make that determination and
see
they're given ample time to do the very
important task of carefully examining
and scrutinizing that information so
that when they make a determination that
an eua
should be granted
that they do so in a way that you can be
sure
that you're dealing with a safe and
effective vaccine so the fda is not
delaying anything the fda needs the
information
not all of which has been presented to
them yet
to make a determination and i think
there's a misinterpretation
that they're holding on
to data that they should be moving on
that's not the case at all
uh can you explain a little bit further
uh though why it has been difficult to
get uh you know it seemed like it wasn't
effective uh the first vaccine that
pfizer had been studying
wasn't effective or not to the level
that they were looking for um so you
know it is obviously up to pfizer to
make the determination whether they seek
emergency use or not uh but
you know from your from your vantage
point what happened there um and you
know what are what are some of the
things that you're seeing uh companies
now do uh in developing vaccines that
may
uh you know be more effective in finding
a vaccine that works in toddlers
well i think we likely will have it the
question is what is the precise dose in
the dose regimen
for pfizer they started off with a
two-dose vaccine for children
in that cohort from six months to two
years and then two years to up to five
years old
and as it turns out a two dose regimen
did not meet the criteria
that were preset
to make it be available to really be
evaluated enough for the efficacy for an
eua and so they then went to the trial
on a three dose regimen which is what's
going on now and the data are being uh
collected and analyzed there so it's
really a question of getting the right
dose in the right dose
regimen
we continually try to improve on that
with newer vaccines including vaccines
for children
and so uh you know with moderna asking
to to seek emergency use authorization
uh is that a sign that based off of
their trials that they are seeing
efficacy with this this vaccine at this
point because i know pfizer had put
forward the request but then pulled it
back
um so just kind of curious uh what does
this really dictate here um in terms of
moderna's potential success in trials
that they're well
yeah
when modernist submits data to the fda
they do so
under the assumption
that the data will be good enough for an
eua i can't comment on that because i
haven't seen the data and i'm not the
fda
so right now when the fda gets all the
data that they need
they will expeditiously analyze the data
and make a determination
based on what they do very well is a
very careful scrutiny of the safety and
efficacy of the data
okay great thank you i know we're all
hungry for that data
um when do you think we'll see a toddler
vaccine do you think we'll see it this
summer or um potentially later based on
what you're hearing
well you're asking the same question
five different ways
and i'm telling you the answer and i'm
being very consistent with one answer
and that is when the fda gets the data
and the data are in a way where they
deem it
that is sufficient for an eua
then they will make that pronouncement
and i certainly am not going to get
ahead of the fda sure to make any
pronouncing about when they're going to
do that they will do that expeditiously
as they always do things expeditiously
sure just i just saw a report saying a
top fda official was saying potentially
as early as june
all right
um
has the omicron variance infection rate
affected or convoluted studies being
conducted on the toddler age group
because it is more infectious um
you know so if if our vaccines we're
still getting infected how does that
affect something like a trial in
children if if the variants now are more
infectious they're not looking at the
same variants that maybe were less
infectious well yeah we've had omicron
now for a bit
so there has been sufficient information
i believe in the omicron era to make a
determination
as to the efficacy of a vaccine in the
omicron era okay okay great
um do you envision a time when a cova
vaccine will be among the early
childhood battery of vaccines
you know i think that really is too too
soon to make any determination on that
because we are still now in certain
phases of a pandemic
and when things stabilize into a steady
state
uh and again as i said in answer to your
previous questions we don't know when or
what level that will be
then i think it will be easier to
determination to determine if in fact
you want to make this
one of the regular childhood vaccines
but i do not think we can make that
determination now okay all right um one
of the earlier realizations of the
pandemic was that children who
contracted the virus did not for the
most part
get as ill as adults um we know now that
as many as 75 percent of children have
already been infected with coronavirus
since the pandemic began uh how is
thinking about children in the
coronavirus evolved over time uh you
know do we have a clear idea yet about
why the virus behaves as it does in
children as opposed to adults
no we don't have a very clear
explanation of why that's the case there
are certain
hypotheses that have not been proven uh
maybe due to so-called innate immunity
that the children have that make it less
likely that they get severity of disease
we don't know the answer so if i surmise
it'll become a sound bite and that's not
good
so i want some eyes uh we don't know try
that so having said that
having said that
uh i think we better be careful
uh and i don't think i know we better be
careful
about when we say that the virus
doesn't affect children as seriously as
it affects adults
to then make the conclusion that it's
trivial in children
it's not
many children have been infected 12
million or so we've had thousands of
hospitalizations we've had miss
uh the the the the uh the uh uh
inflammatory syndrome
uh
in children which leads in many respects
to a serious outcome you know we've had
children die from this we've had
children hospitalized so although it is
true
that children in general
do not get as severe
an outcome as a cohort than do elderly
people
we shouldn't underplay
the potential seriousness of this in
children even though the numbers are
less
we don't want to be able to then accept
that children it's okay for a child to
be infected and get sick it's not
okay great thank you
um
vaccination rates among children and
young adults remain low
what seems to be holding parents back
from vaccinating their children
is it you know misconception that once
you've had covered you're immune from
additional infection as many kids have
gotten coveted already
and or a combination of other factors
that may be preventing parents from
making that decision to move forward on
a vaccine for their kids
you know i think it's multifaceted i
don't think there's one reason you know
there are some parents who are
inherently anti-vaxx
i mean no matter what you tell them they
just don't want to get vaccinated
themselves or their children
there are others who have understandable
concerns
about safety
and for those people you point to the
very very strong safety record
that these vaccines have and sometimes
when parents don't have all the
information they need
to make a decision through no fault of
their own
they're a bit concerned understandable
and sometimes confused about
whether or not the risk benefit weighs
in favor of the benefit and i think when
you go over all the data
and you carefully analyze it in an
unbiased way
hopefully parents will come to the
conclusion
that it certainly is to the benefit of
the children to get them vaccinated
okay
uh you've decided not to go to the white
house correspondence dinner i'm sorry i
will miss you there on saturday night
you called it a personal choice
but i think it might be instructive for
many of us to hear
how you evaluate risk whether it's you
know a big dinner in a ballroom or a
gathering with friends and family what
factors do you consider
well again they're personal factors and
i think one person's decision
namely my decision not to go to an
individual
social function indoors
is based on a number of things that i
put into my own
personal evaluation of my own risk
and one of the things people need to
understand
you shouldn't judge one person's
decision
to be applicable broadly across the
board to others
because each individual person
has a number of factors some of which
are obvious like age
you can't run away from what your age is
but there may be personal risk factors
that people
don't really want to make public so you
shouldn't question them you should
accept a person's
personal
decision which should not
influence someone else's personal
decision all right uh what are some of
the technologies you've seen deployed to
try to prevent the spread you know we've
seen air filtration systems ionizers
for instance at the white house
correspondence dinner organizers were
approached about using
a uv lighting system that could minimize
viral disbursement
what are your thoughts about these types
of technologies anything that looks
promising to you
or
you know is this
so far you're just seeing sort of maybe
minimal effect from some of these things
uh
that's an unfair question because i
really can't evaluate each and every
technical thing that puts forth anything
particular that that stands out to me
well yeah the one thing is clear
ventilation is really important and
that's the reason why you always say
when you have social events particularly
when you're dealing
with a
number of people congregating and
gathering together
outdoors is much better from a safety
standpoint than indoors and if it is
going to be indoors
to the extent possible
proper ventilation
is something that's very important
okay um are there any variants you're
seeing emerge that are greater cause for
concern either related to infectious
rate or other factors than recent
variants like omicron or are we getting
to the point where
ovarian is a variant as a variant we're
that we're seeing a lot of things
cropping up so just your thoughts on
that
no i wouldn't say a variant as a variant
as a variant because if you would have
said that you would have really been
knocked on your back
with delter and then followed by getting
knocked out again with omicron so
we have to be careful there are
sub-lineages like we're seeing
sub-lineages of omicron that may be 20
25 30 percent more transmissible
which means it spreads more rapidly but
doesn't necessarily give you any more
severity of disease
but we've always got to be on the
lookout and very very careful and
vigilant
about a variant that might come along
that might be different enough that it
really seriously evades the protection
that you get
from vaccination and boosting as well as
from prior infection so you always got
to be on your guard
for a variant that's different enough
that it really causes a significant
amount of difficulty
okay um i'm going to ask a few questions
from the audience that are coming in
um this one comes from alexander 10 of
cbs news
uh what does dr fauji make of reports of
rebound symptoms in people who finished
a course of pacslovid do you think more
people should be eligible to receive
paxlovid
all right two separate questions a
little bit unrelated but appropriate
questions and good questions
uh there are anecdotal
stories which are what anecdotes are
of people who have taken paxlavid in the
acute phase within three to five days
have done well
for a few days and then when the drug is
stopped they appear to have a rebound
either a rebound
in test positivity
or rebound usually of mild symptoms the
drug is still clearly very effective
in preventing you from progressing to
requiring hospitalization the 90
efficacy seems to be holding strong
that issue of
real or not rebound phenomenon
is really being looked at very carefully
to determine
what the extent of is and it is it a
real phenomenon because right now
it's still at the level of anecdotal
reports and when you have anecdotal
reports the best thing to do which is
being done
is to put together a study
to try and validate or not what those
anecdotes are and what to do about it if
they are
real
that's the answer to the first question
the second question
i and a number of my colleagues
including dr ja
and others
good morning
well as you know yesterday
the president of the united states put
forth a formidable package
uh to help the ukrainians fight for
democracy their democracy
our democracy
uh it is strong in terms of what it will
do in terms of
assisting with security there uh it is
strong in terms of what it do to help
the economy as well as the humanitarian
assistant i'm very proud of the
president this is such a moment for him
where he has brought people together
mobilized
the
nato in a strong way
working at a pace that we're all
moving together on so many initiatives
recognizing the courage of the ukrainian
people
they have said to me
when they're here they may have more
troops we have more motivation
our troops have more motivation
this is historic
and i thank the president
uh for the careful
consideration he gave to what would be
in the package
our country and the democracy is well
served by this president
who had for so many years was on the
foreign affairs committee so he knows
the territory knows the personalities he
knows the possibilities
uh for again on top of that as vice
president of the united states and now
as president he brings his knowledge
of the again the issues the intelligence
the personalities the possibilities
this is really
something very very important that he
has done
for democracy recognizing that
part of russia's um goal is to diminish
democracy it's the
debate between autocracy
and democracy
or
more specifically dictatorship
and freedom
so i'm again we what we hoped to do is
we were ready with our appropriations
committee to start writing as soon as we
got the numbers from the office of
management and budget and the
president's announcement made public and
we hope to as soon as possible
pass that legislation
as we some of you were here yesterday
when we talked about lower cost
at the pump and so we are proceeding
with our legislation in terms of uh
stopping the exploitation of the
consumer
price gouging and and the rest and
congress madame chair said uh
maria
cantwell uh to have her legislation to
do the uh
stabilization in terms of prices and the
rest
uh the
food prices are affected by
the cost of fertilizer cost of fuel and
the rest so all of this is about
lowering prices lowing prices at the
pump lowering prices at the grocery
store and putting a very strong watchful
eye on the
corporate america who has a business
plan in some instances
that is about profits at the expense of
america's working families
and also about lowering cost prices
lowering wages as they raise prices
increase their profits
the um
so much of what is challenging us now in
our economy relates to
supply chain
when you have lower supply you have
higher cost
and we are so excited about the competes
act and how we are moving on that
yesterday i met with some of the chairs
of the committee uh to be ready because
next week that the distinguished leader
in the senate has said
that they will be
hopefully finishing the motions to
instruct
next week in the senate which will
enable us to go
to a conference and we hope to do that
as soon as possible
this competes act is so important
because of
chips chips chips chips and
semiconductors you all know that
it takes a thousand chips to make a car
2000 to make an electric car for example
many other products are dependent on the
use of chips and we have to be making
them at home
supply chain but that's 52 billion in
our bill over 40 billion dollars
for supply chain
issues and how we
support manufacture here at home bring
it home make it in america and do so in
a way that gives us independence
self-sufficiency
for our country and so that we have our
preeminence
in the world in terms of manufacturing
and that therefore lowering cost
and a third part of that is education
and research
and apprenticeships that many more
people can participate
and how we go forward in this new
independent self-sufficient way for
america where we're not depending on the
factors of protection from other
countries
which
can be held up whether we're talking
covet holding it up or you're talking uh
ukraine holding it up uh for whatever
reason we cannot be dependent and that
so this legislation is really
transformative our goal is always to
make make sure people can survive
but we have to do better than that we
want them to succeed
in order for that to happen we have to
be transformative
and how we have our public policy in
order to work with the private sector
with the nonprofit sector with the
academic world and the rest uh to
involve many more people
in
our
industrial base and
and again in our education uh to get us
to the place where we we were preeminent
decades ago other countries copied our
model of research and academic uh
excellence and then
our jobs went offshore
because it was cheaper
and now we're knowing that that was very
costly to go offshore we need to come
home
so with that we have quite a full plate
ukraine
price at the pump all part of lowering
cost and again competes to take us to a
different place
any questions
uh quick question what do you make of
the recent recordings that showed that
uh mr mccarthy
reported that he knew that his uh his
members were in danger of danger and but
it's because since then he has not
wanted to punish anybody from all those
arguments
but his recordings show that he
knew
you know we're here largely as
legislators that's what i love about
this place because we legislate
to make law listen to the people
make laws that meet their needs
to improve their lives what you're
talking about i'm not going to comment
on except to say this
it was interesting to me
uh that the leader talked about the
concern that he had
if in fact those were his words which
that's up to you to decide
that he was concerned about
his members causing